Black Panther is a hugely important
Marvel character hugely important in the
history of comic and it felt like the
best way to introduce him was within
Captain America Civil War when there was
an opportunity in the Civil War
development process where we needed
another character he was the one and
only person on the list introducing
Black Panther was really exciting for us
and sort of fortified our beliefs that
he deserved his own standalone movie
we put together a calf and a crew among
the best we've ever assembled led by our
director Ryan Putin and the economy
exists in a gray area in addition to
being a soldier he has a more important
job which is a politician he's
constantly making these choices in the
fog of politics in the fog of war we
deal with royalty we deal with royal
families but unlike our other film it's
right here on earth you get to explore
different cultures in different aspects
of our world for black panther in the
world of Wakanda it's finding those
real-life touchstones that we think
gives the film and integrity yet still
making it something that you've never
seen before
hey youtubers is Charlie let's break
down some of this black panther this
will be one of the first of many Black
Panther Avengers videos that will be
coming this year so be sure to subscribe
to get everything I'll be doing
giveaways and all of them all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber we
have a comment on this video about Black
Panthers stuff it's for a copy of the
Doctor Strange DVD I always announce
winners at the end of videos like they
say Black Panther is it going to look
like anything you've seen before in the
Marvel Universe we've been to Eastern
Europe but we've never been to this part
of Africa with the exception of the
brief visit during Avengers age of
Ultron with the tie-in to Ulysses Klaw
who's actually been spotted on set
recently it's going to be so fun to see
Andy Serkis comeback now a lot of the
movies being filmed in South Korea but
obviously Black Panther is going to be
an infinity war so there's a lot of
stuff happening in Atlanta where Marvel
films most of its movies but most of the
Wakanda stuff they're filming in South
Korea that's just because of film
credits I know a lot of people are
wondering why they don't actually film
in Africa sometimes it's just cheaper
for them to film in different places in
the world that's the only reason but
they're sort of teasing that a big part
of the movie isn't just going to be him
kicking ass and I'll talk about that in
a second but it's also him working as a
politician because he is king of Wakanda
now so he's kind of like the midpoint
between Tony Stark and Captain America
Captain America always thinks with his
heart wants to do the right thing Tony
Stark is more of the gray area thinking
more like a politician like a business
owner so sometimes he makes choices that
aren't super popular so a lot of that is
serving the Black Panther plot where
decisions that his father made are
coming back to haunt him like ulysses
klaw who was branded the last time he
tried to steal vibranium some of this
concept art looks like it's from their
vibranium mines the pants are here that
you see in the [ __ ] they talk about
the fog of war I like to use that better
for with the actual fog sort of covering
up this giant statue of a panther that's
made of vibranium giant vibranium
Panther but really all this is just
meant to give you a taste of how
different how advanced and cultured it
looks compared to the rest of the world
even compared to the United States or
Europe or any of the other places that
we've been in the Marvel Universe like
when they were in Johannesburg fighting
that giant Hulk buster
versus hope fight it look relatively
decrepid compared to what's going on
here so that's why they've been so
isolationist because they have such a
precious resources giving them access to
all these wonderful things all this
education science technology so they've
advanced much faster than the people
around them but when you're sitting on
that kind of a goldmine as a culture
over a long period of time you tend to
get very paranoid that was kind of the
idea at the beginning of civil war the
entrance of Wakanda opening up its
borders
when vibranium was stolen from us and
used for a very terrible thing used by
Ultron and sokovia to kill all those
people they decided that that was the
end of their isolationism so now Black
Panther actually has to deal with the
reality of that not everybody in Wakanda
agrees with them Marvel is going to be
rolling out all kinds of educational
materials just to help familiarize
people with the character throughout the
end of the year into next year because
one year from today the movie is going
to be coming out and there are a lot of
people who are familiar with the
character but they don't know him the
way they know spider-man Captain America
Iron Man the other characters that
they've been living with in the movies
for the last 10 years or so so here's 10
really important things about the
character number 10 Black Panther is
actually considered the first black
superhero in mainstream comics he
debuted in 1966 so even though the
movies coming out next year this year is
his 50th anniversary Tana haaziq Oates
has been writing this really amazing
black panther run since the end of
Secret Wars it's kind of his version of
rebirth - just meant to familiarize
people with the culture sort of convey
some of the majesty of the character in
how cool he is so if you're looking to
pick up Black Panther I would recommend
starting with that run but there are a
couple other runs that I mentioned on
this list so number 9 Panthers rage is
actually considered Marvel's first real
graphic novel back in 1973 starting with
jungle action number five it was sort of
a loose collection of adventures focused
on Black Panthers character before he
actually got his solo title in 1977 but
most of you know number eight that Black
Panther is just a title that's passed
down to the person who leads Wakanda in
the comics his father was black panther
his sister was black panther for a while
so it's not always a father to something
it's just something that's
passed down through leadership but you
see in civil war he's wearing his
father's ring that's the ring of a
leadership it's more of a political
royalty thing in the movies the mantle
of black panther seems like it was
passed down before all this happened
seven the heart shaped curves that he
takes it gives him Captain America level
abilities without actually being a
metahuman so he has superhuman strength
superhuman speed he's extra durable
because of the vibranium weave suit so
the whole point of that Chase during
Captain America Civil War was to just
show you what a badass he is
[Music]
he's able to outrun Captain America and
run down a motorcycle but on top of that
he also has a PhD in physics from Oxford
University so we might not be Tony Stark
level smart but he's basically a more
intelligent version of Captain America
which i think is kind of funny number
six that enables him to take down
villains as big as Mephisto that's right
I mean he's go toe-to-toe with Captain
America the other Avengers of similar
power levels no problem but he's also
fought and beaten Mephisto which is just
way beyond that number five he married
storm back in 2006 in the comics one of
Marvel's most high-profile marriages
ever stor marrying black panther made
them the power couple of the Marvel
Universe literal power and metaphorical
power because of the political power
they wilted she was princess of her
tribe so it was like a royal marriage
they an old the marriage in 2012 so
never forget that even if something
really big happens in the comics it
always gets rolled back eventually
Marvel is kind of doing that with their
comics right now things are returning to
status quo by the end of this year
number four big WTF here Wesley Snipes
almost played a version of the character
in the movies back in the 90s now this
was before blade happened but the
project never panned out so it was never
to be but a lot of people were wondering
because they're talking about doing more
blade stuff in the Marvel Universe
maybe we'll see more Wesley Snipes but
it would probably be blade related if he
did come back number three this will
actually make you love chadwick boseman
all the more so he's this really amazing
playwright stage director considered
giving up acting until he was cast in
the Jackie Robinson movie which did
amazing it was an amazing portrayal sort
of reigniting his passion and that's
what got him the role of black panther
the Marvel people watching his
performance in that movie too behind the
scenes civil war stuff he was originally
a much bigger character before Marvel
got the rights to spider-man Kevin Feige
always says they have multiple plans
depending on what things work out what
contractual arrangements happen behind
the scenes so Black Panther was always a
very important part of civil war but you
have to imagine that maybe 10 or 15
minutes of footage that didn't make it
into the film because they got
spider-man you
would had just been more backstory for
his character but because they're doing
the solo film
we'll just see all that when we get to
next February in number one he wielded
the Infinity Gauntlet like a badass
during Secret Wars one of the best
reveals from the end of that story
there's actually a gauntlet assembled
from infinity gems from all different
realities the Doctor Strange has left
behind after he's died that black
panther wield while he's waiting for
Reed Richards to help take down Doctor
Doom
who's wielding the power of the
beyonders so we just one of the people
in the movies that has potential to
wield infinity gems wield the Infinity
Gauntlet at some point even though this
first infinity war film will just be
panels assembling the gauntlet in a
racing half of all life in the galaxy or
at least trying to so let me know in the
comments what do you guys most hype
about for black panther we're going to
be getting a whole lot of black panther
later this year
remember what Fox did when Deadpool was
coming out all the hardcore fans really
understood the character were totally
down for the movie but they wanted to
get wider audiences to go and get jazzed
up about it so they're going to do the
same thing for Black Panther just try to
educate all the people that don't read
comics so whatever they drop it won't be
quite as ridiculous as the Deadpool
stuff obviously a very different type of
character but it's going to be a lot of
fun to take a deep dive into the
character through the rest of the year
so what's going to happen next is is
there's new spider-man homecoming
there's new Star Wars Episode eight so
I'll try to post those videos as fast as
possible Star Wars Fridays coming
tomorrow it's going to be awesome
congratulations to Tobias to the latest
Doctor Strange DVD giveaway winner
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video I'll just
announce the winner the next time I post
a Marvel video thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys in the next
video you can click here to watch the
Thor teaser again and you can click here
for that Doctor Strange post-credit
scene
you